we begin in Sudan where yet another
ceasefire between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces has
been repeatedly violated the
humanitarian situation is fast
deteriorating with the warring generals
showing little appetite to negotiate
civilians continue to flee the capital
Khartoum and other battle zones as
foreign governments push forward with
the evacuation of their Nationals Heber
Morgan begins our coverage and a warning
her report contains graphic images
residents of hartum tried to escape on
the first day of a 72-hour ceasefire
announced by the wearing sides they'd
been caught up amid heavy bombardment
for 11 days now they're faced with other
difficulties in trying to leave the
scarcity of fuel has made it hard even
to reach bus stations the cost of
transportation to other cities has
skyrocketed those who have cash
are getting out
heading to the Egyptian border
brought up trying to see if they can get
to the Ethiopian border and whatever but
there's a lot of many hundreds thousands
of other Sudanese who don't have that
luxury and I don't know what they're
going to do the poor majority who can't
leave are the most exposed
we are really suffering to begin with
fuels have run out bakeries are closed
and we cannot find a loaf of bread the
same for meat prices have soared one
kilo of tomatoes cost nearly nine
dollars let alone the sharp shortage of
medicines we cannot live here or even
leave to other areas we call on the
government to do something to end this
war at least to allow us to flee and
despite the U.S brokered humanitarian
ceasefire the fighting has continued in
parts of the Sudanese capital hartum and
elsewhere in umderman a shell landed in
a roomy Hospital wounding over a dozen
people including patients and medical
staff al-rumi hospital is the latest in
the capital to be hit by artillery
forcing its closure and adding to a
worsening situation its patients were
evacuated to a nearby medical facility
that was already dealing with an influx
of people injured from nearly two weeks
of fighting
ending the war is not what the two
wearing sides meant by the ceasefire its
aim according to the warring parties is
to allow citizens and residents to
access health care or move to Safe zones
while foreign Nationals are being
evacuated but while those foreign
Nationals are being taken to the safety
of their own homes abroad these Sudanese
are being forced to leave theirs
humanitarian impact of this crisis will
be harsh before this crisis Sudan hosted
more than one million refugees and 3.7
million were internally displaced the
U.N says at least 20 000 Sudanese
refugees have arrived in Chad and on
Sudan's border with Ethiopia a similar
scene Sudanese civilians and Nationals
from up to 23 countries all desperate to
leave Heber Morgan Al Jazeera cartoon
the UN Secretary General has called on
Sudan's warring generals to silence the
guns Antonio guterres told the U.N
security Council the conflict will not
be resolved on the battlefield our
diplomatic editor James Bay's reports
in its first open meeting on Sudan since
the crisis started the security Council
received a dismal picture of the
situation inside the country with the
U.N Secretary General telling them
violence could soon spread these 10 days
of violence
and Chaos are heartbreaking
a prolonged full-scale war is unbearable
to contemplate
Sudan border seven countries all of
which have either been involved in
conflicts or sincere civil unrest over
the past decade
it is a gateway to the Sahel where
insecurity and political instability are
making an already catastrophic
humanitarian situation even worse the
secretary General's special
representative for Sudan was recently
relocated from Khartoum joining an 800
kilometer Overland Convoy to Port Sudan
from where he briefed the council the
two generals continue trading
accusations and issuing competing claims
of control over key installations
there is yet no unequivocal sign that
either is ready to seriously negotiate
suggesting that both think that securing
a military victory over the other is
possible
this is a miscalculation
for now the security Council has been
unable to agree a further statement on
Sudan there are plenty of things they
could do they could accuse the two rival
generals of war crimes even put
sanctions on them but they know the
International Community for now must
continue to deal with both men to try
and keep the patchy ceasefires
continuing James Bay's Al Jazeera of the
United Nations
Sudan's ambassador to the U.N called on
members of the rapid support forces to
lay down their weapons and integrate
into the army he told the security
Council at a solution to the conflict
will be found
I do not need physical evidence to prove
the scale of the damages and suffering
from this Rebellion but despite all of
the above Sudan remains a United State
assuming its functions with
responsibility we did not declare a
state of emergency the events have not
had a regional spillover Sudan will
defeat these difficult circumstances we
hope to end the rebellion and recall on
the council to understand the
exceptionally urgent situation and Grant
Sudan the time it needs to come up with
adequate opportunities to achieve
positive progress that would bring Sudan
to a better position and revive the
demands of the Revolution Freedom peace
and Justice
thousands of people are fleeing from
Sudan to neighboring Chad ahmedress
reports from China in charge just over
the border from Sudan
this is a region that has seen that has
hosted thousands hundreds of thousands
in fact between 400 to 600 000 refugees
from the Darfur region and with the
United Nations predicting 170
000 or even 200 000 people crossing over
into Chad things are getting desperate
on our way to fight China here we we're
seeing truckloads of the world food
program trying to reach this area so as
to start the distribution of food and we
understand that hundreds more are
waiting to cross into Child near the
border area 60 kilometers from where we
are now at adre and basically the world
food program is trying to quickly deploy
as many trucks as it can to get to that
particular location with the two sides
still violating ceasefire agreement
Foster the Eid ceasefire agreement and
now the 72-hour uh ceasefire agreement
there is little confidence that this
conflict will be resolved anytime soon
and this is giving eight agencies like
the world food program the United
Nations side commissioner for refugees a
lot of concern that things will get
worse in the coming days and they are
actually desperate they don't have the
enough resources to deal with the
problem at hand at the moment that's the
situation right now at Fortuna and 65
kilometers away from here is a border
between Chad and Sudan which is the town
of address hundreds of refugees are
waiting for the United Nations and donor
agencies to help as much as they can